you know as we going around massage
massage this is this is bodied up black
dude massaging these big girls it's not
YouTube it's also on Instagram that's
good and everybody's asking the question
would you let this [ __ ] massage
your girl he's like a very handsome
well-built man and he's rubbing this ass
but she's big this is large and
generally when I go get like real legit
massages like I make sure female you say
female right only always dudes [ __ ]
hands in my ass right Oh would you down
a man no but I [ __ ] a horse no I
[ __ ] up I was at the [ __ ] Airport I
had three hours to kill you did one of
those things and I said I said give me a
massage ago you want to go to the
[ __ ] driver room like yeah I'm at the
airport
dude I didn't even say female I didn't
say theme and you don't have a Chinese
one back there and I lay down and the
[ __ ] dude I swear to god no he was a
gigantic man with the biggest [ __ ]
hands he was an African American he was
an African American it was worked on my
legs dude recently coffee your boss
comfortable I'm and from that point on
today the dude I [ __ ] go out I just
walk right on my Bimmer you get at the
female you have a female like strong
strong girls suits like a fat girl thing
is hands I get it
they're [ __ ] tired and massaging
people all day so that's why they use
the elbows right but elbows is too
strong boys lazy no no seriously I'm not
even gonna give her away that's how you
get to certain spot there's anything
between there's a maybe to come out
before me and I don't even want to give
this out this is about yeah dude if the
girl is like a hundred and five pounds
yeah did I run to this massage you stood
on you she had this metal contraption
over mine she stood up she the whole
semester with her feet I'm at the point
where I can't handle bozo mom too old
for elbows it's too much hands I get it
the hands I get it they give massages
all day they were trying to save their
hands so that's where the user elbows
but the in-between oh my god is two feet
come on Santa Monica Boulevard guy
massage me Russian guy comes in sick I'm
looking at him after he's done and he's
just being and I'm looking at me off
like he's just got a dead face and I go
I go do you do do you wrestle or train
he goes judo oh yeah I said did you
compete he said I have one gold medal
Sydney Olympics I looked them up enough
legit
that's a shirt he was an Olympic gold
medalist in judo let this microcycle how
do you train that when you train what
are you doing he goes judo I said but
when you lift it what were you lifting
weights a lot and he said no just judo
like well I tipped about a [ __ ] tip
tomorrow
while we're still dating involuntarily I
was hanging on my neck [ __ ] it is a
phenomenal [ __ ] fight though this is
a very very good fight no more massage
another thing no no no he's done this is
the last fight here's one of things that
happen